[Music]
some actors stay in character through an
entire suit and some well
they just never let it go maybe later
we'll have a five dollar milkshake yeah
how about a royal with
cheese see what i mean
pup fiction was a masterpiece but these
two think it was all about a dance
contest that's not true sam pulp fiction
was about a lot of people name one
three tomatoes are walking down and she
still knows the lines folks
it was all about the contents of this
briefcase that is a bold statement do
tell
all the murder and mayhem that occurred
in 2045 minutes was about what was in
here and at the end of the film that
revealed that the audience still was
left to draw their own conclusions about
the meaning of existence damn did
couldn't help you write that
you know what you should do you should
teach a master class actually i do
now should we finally reveal what's
actually in this briefcase oh yeah
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
[Applause]
javier bardem being the ricardo's
benedict cumberbatch the power of the
doll
andrew garfield ticktick boom
will smith
king richard
denzel washington the tragedy of macbeth
and the oscar goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man uh
richard williams
um
was a fierce
defender of his family
in this
time in my life
in this
moment
i am
overwhelmed by what god is calling on me
to do and be in this world
making this film
i got to protect
anjanu ellis
who was one of the most
the strongest
most delicate people i've ever met
i got to protect
sanaya
and demi
the two actresses that played venus and
serena
[Applause]
i'm being called on
in my life
to love people
and to protect people
and to be a river to my people
now i know
to do what we do
you got to be able to take
abuse you got to be able to have people
talk crazy about you
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you got to smile and you got to
pretend like that's okay
but richard williams
and what i loved thank you dee
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
[Applause]
it's like
i want to be a vessel
for love
i want to say
thank you to venus and serena i just
spit i hope they didn't see that on tv
um
i want to say thank you to venus and
serena and the tire williams family for
entrusting me with your story
that's what i want to do i want to be an
ambassador
of that kind of
love
and care and concern
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
this is a beautiful moment and i'm not
i'm not i'm not crying
for winning an award it's not it's not
about winning an award for me it's about
being able to shine light
on all of the people tim
and and trevor and zach
and sanaya and demi and anjanu and the
entire cast and crew of king richard and
venus and serena the the entire williams
family
art imitates life i look like the crazy
father like they said
i look like crazy father just like they
said about richard williams
[Applause]
but love will make you do crazy things
um
to my mother
um
a lot of this moment is really
complicated for me but to to my mother
um
she didn't want to come out she was had
her knitting friend she has a knitting
crew that she's in philly watching
watch it with um
being able to love and care for my
mother my family my wife um i'm taking
up too much time
thank you
for
this honor
thank you for
this moment and thank you on behalf of
richard and and oricine the entire
williams family um
thank you uh uh hoping academy invites
me back thank you
[Applause]
you